you
here we go live streaming against the
beast so here's the plan my strat oh
I've had good success against the
computer when it does this my plan is to
have the center closed and have an
attack against the king so I'm looking
for closed centers and and what more a
space advantage on the side where the
computer castles and that's what I'm
always looking forward to but I've seen
this line before and it's going to end
up playing the pawn up here and we enter
a much much different position not one
that's gonna be closed
I really can't force that unless I
played this right now maybe I could do
this see if I do this there's gonna be a
five Bishop c5 let me try this Knight g4
d4 I want to kick him away right now
it's gonna be takes here yeah it loves
doing that stuff doesn't it
alright I'm gonna grab the piece fine
look at the center it has now look at
that Center and it's ready to sweep down
here and grab another pawn what hang on
to him though bishop in pawn push yeah
look at this Center isn't it beautiful
beautiful Center I should probably
challenge it right now c3 c3 Bishop g4
pawn takes pawn
efore that's annoying c3 Bishop g4 rook
here let's give that a shot
wait huh
oh I get to break up this pawn Center
okay let's do it
I've got some loose pieces here oh boy
okay let's block that yeah I feel like
I'm gonna get crunched oh boy
close to happening I think um I'm up a
piece in this this has to be good it's
computers bluffing
it's just bluffing
okay can i successfully castle without
losing a ton of material I like that I
got in c3 and then takes here 2 minutes
50 seconds plenty of time if I take here
there's night seat - I can't allow that
I think I have to just take the knight
Knight takes Queen takes oh I could turn
out pretty dangerous I think I gotta go
with it though Bishop g2 I'm on the rook
rook da Tao
bishop here rook da Queen c1 what's
wrong with that let's see let's find out
Queen takes B - okay
Queen c1 queen c1 Bishop b4 what a bug
what a bug this computer what about
night here Knight c3 uh-huh
what do you have now I get throwing to
check on c6 but I don't know how scared
the computer would be about that Knight
c3 one two three four five I'm up a pun
I'm up a point minute thirty clock's
ticking
quit your talking and make some moves
here Knight c3 Knight c3 Queenie -
actually how am i Knight c3 Queen e2
rook d1 it takes forever but I think
I'll be that I have to worry about
Bishop d3 stuff Oh should I just Castle
and give material back no that's just
crazy Tim isn't it what about Queen c1
Bishop takes and then I don't know what
I want to do less than a minute
castles Bishop takes Knight takes Queen
takes let's just go here I might never
be able to castle that's it's probably
oh my goodness guys
yeah I definitely saw that one and that
was a beautiful that was beautiful
calculation you catch all that yeah
you're really you're really good right
there right you're defended very nicely
on d2 now aren't you yeah okay okay you
have not seen the last of me
reason